you are a father who is about to send
your oldest off to college how you
feeling about that I'm crushed I I'm so
excited but then heartbroken I mean it
goes by so fast for all those parents
out there oh it was his last week Nathan
uh I read her a long letter I broke down
crying like a little baby in front of
her
I can't I couldn't help it I have two
Natasha's 18. I'll be dropping her off
in August in Ann Arbor and Michigan and
uh boy I'm gonna be if you don't mind me
asking if you would indulge us what were
some of the things that you wrote in
that letter that you wanted to say to
your daughter because there's a lot of
parents that are in your same position I
am yeah right now yeah that's a great
question I'll tell you how I I couldn't
finish a letter because I started you
know breaking down it was at my house we
had a bunch of my family over and I
basically said you know I'm supposed to
be your role model and here you are at
18 and you're my role model